allowing ourselves to exist in that
middle ground makes us look as though
we're disconnected or we don't have an
opinion and sometimes it's all right to
say
i don't know or i think i've got a good
idea but i'm willing to listen to other
people before i make my mind up people
hate that people are so scared of that
corridor
of indecision that they quickly enter a
room and so we find ourselves
just picking aside
dottie how are you i'm very well how you
doing chris
fantastic thank you for being here could
you have realized before
writing a book on outrage just how
timely mid 2020 would be for it to be
published
you know what's crazy for the past
nine months i've been like we gotta drop
the book down we've gotta drop the book
now oh i wish it was coming out now
oh we need to outrage is a constant
carousel anytime i would have released
this book
people would have said what are the odds
you've dropped it in a this is the world
we live in so i think people are hyper
aware
now but i think because i've written the
book
every couple of weeks there's been
something that has felt really timely
and i've been like oh they're cancelling
david williams we need to we need to
release the book
oh no no no it's jk rowling the book
needs to come out
um it is it's just constant and that i
think that's why the book was needed
because any time would have been timely
the stock price of outrage
is uh is constantly on the up isn't it
it's like tesla or something at the
moment so
why did you write a book about outrage a
while ago let's forget this year
why did you write a book on outrage
already yeah so i started this book
two years ago um well two and a half
years ago it took me two years to write
it
and i'm somebody who has been one of
those voices online
i've had arguments with strangers i've
tried to convince people that
i've never met that their thinking is
wrong and that their belief system is
flawed
i've written an open letter to piers
morgan i've been
that person that i now can't stand right
i've had pointless arguments i've been
outraged
about trivial things and i kind of
reached
breaking point i'd say and i sort of had
an epiphany
and i think when people read this book
they'll each have their epiphany moment
for me it was january 2018
and there was outrage about a h m hoodie
which had been placed on a black boy and
it said coolest monkey in the jungle
now of course you can look at that
through a critical lens and say what
that this is
completely tone death it's racist
for me though it warranted a
conversation
about who the hell works at h m and
why did nobody flag that this could
offend people
i don't think the intention was to
offend people i think it was more
symptomatic of their
employment structure and how flawed it
must be
if there's nobody from the stage of
idea conception to it making it onto the
h m website
if nobody in that conveyor belt of
decision making
says oh maybe we don't put the monkey
hoodie on the black kid
if there's nobody in that in that system
that notices that there's a problem in
the system
but that doesn't warrant knee jerk
outrage because this is clearly it's not
intentional
racism by h m a a
multi-million revenue company is not
going to one day wake up and say should
be a bit racist today
yeah it's hard to throw it all away it
acts of negligence
or just idiocy right rather than
maliciousness
exactly and that was my light bulb
moment as i kind of watched
the world up in arms outraged h
m a racist boycott h m they've done this
deliberately
in that moment i was like outrage has
gone too far
because it's stifling conversation and
we're not gonna get anywhere by having
this knee-jerk
reaction being quick to to anger
doesn't work in every situation and i
felt as though we'd over inflated the
outrage bubble
and it had burst for me in that moment
um and so i wrote an article about it
for the guardian and from that article
the book was born
i absolutely love i'm going to read the
the passage that you put in from that
guardian article because
it is so good this is the currency of
outrage published in the guardian 25th
of january 2018.
everyone is offended by everything it's
exhausting keeping up with all the
non-inclusive
misogynistic racist homophobic
transphobic xenophobic ageist
culturally appropriating body shaming
propaganda that seems to lit the social
meet the social media age
apparently in 2018 almost anything is
subject to the scrutiny of one
marginalized eye or another
being outraged allows you to take the
moral high ground it reaffirms your
moral righteousness
it lets you say i am offended and
therefore i am principled it lets you
jump on the bandwagon and pledge
allegiance to the latest campaign on
your timeline
it gives you a vehicle to add your name
to the narrative
it proves that you are following current
affairs albeit
from the comfortable vantage point of
your instagram feed it allows you to
place yourself
on the virtuous side of the conversation
it says i am woke
and for that reason outrage has become
currency
so you should have done the bloody audio
bookmaker give it to me give it to me
i'll tell you what anyone out there that
needs it doing head up to newcastle but
yeah that
that identifies it to me you're right
and currency is the right word for it
it is it is a sort of tradable commodity
that oh how
how many how many virtue points did you
get today how many virtue points did
you get today i i washed a black
person's feet in the middle of my street
what did you do what i painted some
white lines and tried to take over the
middle of a
city
and and it not even just in a sort of a
figurative sense
um although loved your analogy there um
it genuinely is currency
right you can trade off outrage for
progress in a very real sense
so if you look back at the civil rights
movement
there was so much currency in that
outrage it
prompted change you know the
suffragettes
used the currency in their outrage to
get the
the female vote you know outrage can
give you a return on your investment
it's not sort of merely ornamental it's
not just a
a figment of my imagination this idea of
currency
it really has value you know and i think
what we're doing wrong
is by aimlessly investing it because
outrage is an investment
on an emotional level as well to apply
yourself
to something with genuine outrage
it requires impetus it requires some
real effort on your part so it is an
investment of your time
your emotion your energy i think our
issue is that we don't really look for a
return on our investment
we're just kind of throwing our currency
out there you know
and that is where you devalue outrage
where you no longer
see the value in it you know i think
every outrage exchange
should have an end goal you should be
seeking a return on your investment
otherwise you're just barking at
strangers you know with with no ambition
so that overuse of outrage is diluting
down
the usefulness of outrage exactly so
if you imagine just a few trivial things
that people have been outraged why
because make no mistake there are times
when we
do need to be outraged but if you look
at things we've reacted to
like scarlett johansson being cast to
play
a trans woman jamie oliver's jerk rice
these things are
tone deaf they are poor decisions
but do they warrant outrage
on the same scale as
white supremacy of proven moments of
misogyny
if we just react in the same way to
everything how do you move the needle
when it generally needs to be but it
genuinely needs to be moved you know
if we're loud if the volume is always up
how can you cut through the noise when
you really need to be heard and i think
that's the issue
outrage is just our default setting so
it's lost its power
yeah we need to restore factory settings
you know i mean go
go back a bit so that outrage actually
means something when we get there
i understand so what's the architecture
of
outrage in 2020 is there like a a common
narrative or a common structure that it
always seems to follow
no outrage is so multifaceted and i
think
that's part of the problem with it we
don't recognize
that nuance you know we we lump things
all underneath uh this umbrella of of of
cancer culture which in itself is a myth
but we will put a jk rowling
next to slave owners uh next to
some mistake that um philip schofield
made
and it all gets lumped underneath this
umbrella
of cancelled and actually there's no
metric
system for outrage there's no there's no
threshold that you pass and it's like
okay you're a
you get your badge you are the outrage
badge yeah you get the outrage badge and
it's official you are indeed cancelled
every
situation is unique and it's different
and the issue is
our knee-jerk reaction is the same no
matter what the transgression
and i think that's the issue you know
you
you could be trending number one if
you're a mass murderer
or if you've used somebody's pronoun
wrong
you know you're gonna be trending in the
same way
and you're going to be the topic of
discussion which you never want
rule number one of social media you
never want to be the topic of discussion
right that i think that is something we
should all avoid as being the main
character
on on twitter on any given day but it's
the fact that we kind of
we respond to all of these
transgressions
in the same way and i what my book aims
to do
is to point out that it's not just two
opposite ends of the spectrum
it's not just warrants outrage doesn't
work outrage it's not
if it was that simple i'd have written a
pamphlet and not a book right
it's about recognizing that there are
shades
in between the black and the white and
we need to recognize and identify
all of those different shades and
respond accordingly
rather than just having outrage as our
go-to reaction
something happens i'm outraged something
else happened i'm outraged
it completely as i said devalues it why
are people going to the extreme then why
are they not deciding to use
a more measured response first of all
there's something that i refer to as the
fear of the fence
right we are so scared of sitting on the
fence
because we think oh the the fence is for
people who are
unaffected or uninformed or it's it's a
place of apathy
i can't sit on the fence i've gotta be
either on this side or on that side
and therefore we find ourselves just
often
out of sheer force picking aside
in the moment and having to sustain our
allegiance to that side
although it's not particularly informed
by any real
uh process of of of creating a judgment
it's often us just saying i've got to
pick a side
got to go the moral majority here i
think that is bad
that is wrong cancel them because
we fear that allowing ourselves to exist
in that middle ground
makes us look as though we're
disconnected or we we don't have an
opinion
and sometimes it's all right to say i
don't know
or i think i've got a good idea but i'm
willing to listen to other people before
i make my mind up
people hate that people are so scared of
that
that corridor of indecision that they
quickly enter a room they're like
partly in the [ __ ] corridor do you
know what i mean but better get in a
room
and so we find ourselves just picking
aside and we allow the tide
of that decision to take us you know
you find yourself tethered to this uh
idea that you made um just as a
knee-jerk reaction you find yourself
now pigheadedly defending that idea
because again you can't look wishy-washy
something you maybe didn't necessarily
agree with or understand in the first
place and then yeah you're like [ __ ] i
was just retweeting charlotte
and now i've gotta back up my idea why
the hell do i feel this way
and and that is often why we get these
heated debates
because people are just defending a
point of view
that an arbitrary point of view that
they feel
they need to remain shackled to and of
course the internet is so
noisy it's so loud that in order to cut
through
we feel we need to be as loud and
you know being mildly disgruntled is not
loud enough
on the internet you've got you've got to
be outraged or i can't hear you you know
some ambient displeasure look tepid some
tepid unhappiness
isn't going to make it on top not gonna
cut it if you want some retweets mate
yeah i think that's definitely part of
it i wonder how much of its virtue
signaling
how much of it i'm i i care more than
you because i can use more capital
letters or clap hand emojis
um like you know it it does feel a
little bit
of course so somehow sam harris has this
thing
uh in his most recent podcast which i
thought was phenomenal he calls it
performative communication
and i think that absolutely is what a
whole bunch of this is is occurring
because
a lot of the time if you see one
person's point of view on one topic
you can probably extrapolate out their
point of view on a whole bunch of other
topics as well both real and imagined
if that's the case you're not a real
human like you shouldn't
have you shouldn't have cookie cutter
beliefs
at all ever absolutely absolutely but
our social media feeds are
they're kind of a pr release everything
you post
and everything you say every image you
share is you saying this is who i am
it's my latest pr release
this is what i stand for so we find
ourselves
constantly trying to project this image
of our best bits
you know this is how i feel this is what
this is what i do on the weekends
this is how i bake it's it's your
highlight reel
right and and people find that being
outraged is a great moral
highlight reel it's like look what i
stand for man
i'm for the refugees i'm for the women
i'm for the muslims i'm for it all
look look how good i am and people
become
more concerned with seeming progressive
than being progressive it's more
important that i that i'm
seen to be like this as opposed to
actually being like this and in the book
i am i
explore the neuroscience behind it as
well so there's
there's like loads of science
behind why we act like this right
there's there's an endorphin anybody who
has ever
posted a view that they thought was kind
of specific to them
this is how i feel on a matter and then
they've started to see the
likes and the retweets rack up that is a
rush
that is a biological rush it's endorphin
fueled to be agreed with right
if i go out in the street and i say
hey man pick up your litter
that is bad there's no rush there
because nobody saw me do it
all right if i record a video
of the of uh
petrol company pumping their petrol into
this
picturesque lake and i shamed this
company
and everybody rallies behind me and says
oh my gosh
this is an abomination that's going to
give me
an endorphin rush and therefore we like
to
perform our goodness in front of a crowd
it it becomes more important as i said
to be
seen to be doing the thing as opposed to
just doing it
and that is our innate need
to be celebrated and that's been
weaponized
by having always on communication social
media which is accessible anywhere in
the world yeah
absolutely what are some of your
favorite examples of outrage that you
looked at from the book there's quite a
few different ones that you go through
have you got any
have you got any your favorite hits so
obviously the book
explores the weird and the wonderful
and the warranted at times right let's
not mistake this
for a book that says everybody calm down
this book isn't
saying you know life should be a
free-for-all without consequences
you know it's it's more me saying
people and circumstances are intricate
and they deserve
that level of care when we you know
unpack and dissect them
but with that comes the absolutely
ridiculous
stuff um like austerity day
which fascinated me when i
i wrote the book because you do you get
your usual suspects
that kind of float around
anything contentious like flies on [ __ ]
right and
you get your geminid mills and then your
jackman rose
um and your david lammies and people
that are like oh
there's something here that i think i
need to be a bit angry about
and those those moments are the ones
that fascinate me when they're
ridiculous
so austerity day was
a a private school um
decided that to teach their well-to-do
students
that not everybody has a ladder and a
pantry
at home and a garage that can fit three
cars
they decided to have austerity day to
teach them about the other side of life
and
so they scrapped their bachelorange on
the
lunch menu and gave them like jacket
potatoes just root veg
and a real what they thought was a bog
standard
lunch you know to teach these private
school kids that there's a life out
there unlike your own you're going to
learn about austerity
via a cheap lunch um and there was
uproar
there was genuine uproar um saying that
this was
it fetishized uh working the working
class
um that it was a it was an insult to
people who genuinely live this way
and for me that is one of those
absurd moments right because yes there
are children
that survive on food banks there are
children whose only hot meal
is the meal they go to they go to school
and get that that's their only hot meal
of the day
austerity is a real major issue
you're not going to dismantle that by
slagging off a private school in
southwest london
do you know what i mean and i think our
issue
with matters like this and why it's so
important to highlight in the book
the the ridiculous is because we need to
take down
power structures right there are power
structures that need to be dismantled
there are entire systems that are flawed
and you don't you don't take down the
tree by sort of jumping up at leaves
and that's what so much of our outrage
is it's us like oh
i got a leaf i got i got a leaf i
slagged off h
m you know i mean and
and those those are what what i call
leaves
the sort of the ridiculous moments
what is that yes they are they're
symptomatic of bigger issues but they
themselves are not the bigger issue
yeah it's i really do wonder
how many people that involve themselves
in this performative communication and
decide to go for it full
full chat on twitter i wonder how many
of them actually believe the things that
they're saying because it's quite
effortful
like for me to go and take time out of
my day to get into
big big twitter wars i i need to
i need to be really compelled to do it
you know like
i don't want to just do it because i'm
because i'm bored but i wonder how
what this spread of these people are
that do
create this outrage online truth be told
as much look as much as i joke about it
and i do in the book
i i joke about this issue
um quite a lot if i'm being honest
but i joke
as a vehicle to make uh
quite an important point which i think
is
it's not a laughing matter outrage right
and it's not just
them over there it's not those crazy
people over there virtue signaling
or those crazy people over there that
are just quick to uh
to anger it's it's all of us
and at times we don't realize we're
doing it
because we're not doing this consciously
we're not saying
today i think i'm gonna pretend
to be really pissed off about
anti-semitism
it's not it's not an intentional act
right we go on social media
or on blogs or even in our everyday
conversations
and we tackle the problems we feel are
within our reach
right so much out there is completely
insurmountable or at least it seems
insurmountable
right so you may have some real concerns
about government policy and it just
feels it's insurmountable
how how how do i begin
to topple that it feels as though
something that's
out of your reach but what's within
reach is
judith underscore 87 talking [ __ ]
so we tackle that not because we're bad
people that are pretending to be angry
but because we feel as though that is
some sort of progress it's progress
within my reach it's something i can do
that is within my means you know and
it's important with this book to realize
that it's not
finger-pointing actually it's actually
about saying
we need to analyze and assess ourselves
and figure out how to be more effective
in our communications
because as i say it's not just us going
out there
with uh this intent to be
faux raged we we're quite convinced
that we're doing something you know
we're we're actually convincing
ourselves that
mob justice is social justice quite
often we conflate the two we're like oh
brilliant we're all piling on this thing
look at us go you know we we are part of
a movement
and it's like it's mob justice it's not
actually social justice but
cool get your rocks off you probably
feel quite good in that moment
and it's about it's about channeling
it's about channeling that same
sentiment
but into things that matter so how
do we decipher between true outrage and
full rage because i'm
a fairly i like to think i'm a fairly
sensitive reasonable
person i don't want people to feel
uncomfortable with
the things that are on tv the david
williams from 10 years ago they're both
selected
but i also don't want them to feel
uncomfortable about gender pay gap
all of these different things but as
you've said before there's a line
somewhere there has to be a line that's
drawn so how do we decipher between the
two
there's so much in what you just said
that i would love to unpack
um part of it is in
our needs to be heroes right and
we feel as though and you know who
who quite often feel that way it's kind
of
why allies who almost go to the extreme
where they're like i'm gonna be offended
by everything
on your behalf because
i don't i don't i don't want to be
i don't want to be the image of
privilege i don't want to be the image
of supremacy so i'm going to go the
other way and i'm going to bend over
backwards
and actually that's offensive and that's
offensive and that's offensive
and then you get this sort of
performative i'm on my gap year
um helping out all the orphanages and
it's actually self-serving
it's to kind of it's to negate a
privilege that you feel you have
and that's a big part of the issue with
outrage
where we're doing it not for for the
progress of a cause
but for the positioning of ourselves to
appease ourselves
and make ourselves feel better and feel
like i'm i'm contributing in some way
you know and if it's if it's not
rooted in a genuine
desire for change it's it's not
sustainable
and that's where you get these people
that they seem really progressive and
they seem like great people
but what they care about this week isn't
what they cared about three weeks ago
and then there was something totally
different they cared about a few weeks
before that
because you're trying to care about
everything and i say in the book
and i say to people all the time if you
stand for everything
you're going to knock yourself you'll
never sit down and you'll
con you'll not really make any
contribution to everything you'll be
giving a little bit of yourself
to so many causes and like you say
you'll sign a petition here
and you'll retweet something over here
and then you'll forward something else
to eight friends
but are you committed to changing every
anything
i think i think that's part of the issue
in that we feel obliged to
care about everything there are enough
people
for us to each play our position and
create progress in so many avenues
right the civil rights movement i again
i use it as an example
okay there are incredible
creatives for example james baldwin uh
maya angelou angela davis who had to
kind of park their creativity and be
like i've got to figure out the civil
rights movement first
it's like you can't just be a poet you
can't just be a
a writer we've got we've got to tackle
this issue first and you see that
progress
when people kind of ball themselves into
a fist
right we're kind of busy off being
fingers
these days we're like well i'm over here
doing that i'm over here doing this and
we don't pack the punch of a fist
because we're not concerted
in sustained efforts and i think
that's a real big issue that we need
to care about things but we need to be
unwavering we need to be sustained and
dedicated
in those things which the internet
doesn't always give you room to do
you know if you if you look at what's
trending
if you refresh it in 30 seconds it's
going to be a jumble of new things
in a different order and we feel like
[ __ ] we're talking about this now and we
feel an obligation
to move with the conversation the
conversation moves so
fast online we're not caring about
anything
long enough to actually
create change because we see what
happens when when we do
you get moments like black lives matter
which
wasn't a trending for a day it wasn't
trending for a week it
it forced people to have self-regulating
it created conversations it
it felt like a bit of a social shift
because
it wasn't something that just you
refreshed and it disappeared
and that's where there's so much power
in outrage it's
it's not in in what you say there where
you're like i i i want people to be
happy here and i want people to be happy
here and i want
it's about saying okay i can't be all
things to all people right
right now where can i affect change
where where can i be a strong ally where
can i be committed
to a cause as opposed to trying to stand
for everything
which is bloody exhausting
whose job is it to police people being
foe raged is it nobody's job
right okay so it is nobody's job okay
and this is
this is an important point i make in the
book
this book isn't me saying you know
this is a manual this is a this is a
manual that you must follow
to be correctly outraged it's it's a
road map
right it's like an old school a to zed
where it takes you
is up to you all right if you want it to
take you east it will take you east if
you want to take you west
it will take you west it's me taking a
deep dive and kind of
serving up everything that i found
and one thing that i found is look
outrage is subjective
you know it's like this again this idea
of cancel culture
there's no universal way to establish
if something deserves to be cancelled
something that offends you
may not offend me there may be something
that truly offends me but it doesn't
reflect your lived experience
so you can have empathy but you can't be
outraged on the scale that i am
right so you can't police what i'm
outraged by
just as i can't police what you're
outraged by all right
and often you get these people that are
like oh i don't get it
why is why is everyone overreacting to
this thing that's allegedly transphobic
you're not
you're not trans so you cannot measure
the offense right it's again with
anti-semitism it's been
um on the agenda recently because of
nick cannon
and people are like there's people like
oh gosh but does he mean to be
anti-semitic if you're if you
are not the target
of a topic or if you're not the person
that is directly affected
it is not your place to determine
whether or not the outrage is warranted
what i
urge people to do in this book is to
ensure that when they are outraged they
have
gone through that process of of of
checking with themselves
whether there's a purpose whether
there's whether there's meaning
whether there's reasoning behind this
avenue
you know and i think that's the most
important thing not not us
dictating how other people respond but
in us being responsible for how
we respond you know that's hard though
it's much easier for me to just be
outraged and do a retweet and say
[ __ ] jk rowling i never liked i never
liked harry potter anyway hermione's a
[ __ ]
bloody ron weasley never liked him
um look we we don't give ourselves
enough credit
man for how much we can
steer and curate our own experience
so we often go onto the internet
and as i said we we just respond to
what's already there
yeah so okay everybody's angry about
this thing quite often the people that
are responding to it
didn't consume it firsthand they you
know
quite often we react to things we didn't
watch live or
to things written in newspapers that we
don't read
you know or something that was said on a
tv network
in a country that we don't live in but
we've consumed
this transgression online and now we
feel obliged
to respond to it again absolutely
exhausting
there is enough in your realm
firsthand that you can respond to
we have this thing where we seek out
offense which really frustrates me
we kind of we look for the hot topic of
the day
we say okay what's everybody talking
about okay this is trending there are a
lot of tweets about that
i better put my two pens in and as i i
describe it in the book as the outrage
conga line
right we don't know where it's going we
don't know where it's where it's
where it started [ __ ] it let's all join
we're doing a [ __ ] conga mate
fine and that's that's what these
mass moments of outrage often are people
were
with the david williams book um with the
kids books
right which was um kind of topic of
discussion recently
on social media i read it and i was like
i i sort of i read the threads started
by jack
munro and i i read the threads and i was
like
[ __ ] this book sounds absolutely
awful like his books sound
horrendous this is but then i was like
i've got enough [ __ ] in my day today i
don't need to join the david walliams
pylon
if i'm being completely honest we don't
give ourselves
the credit that we we should be giving
ourselves we don't
we don't harness that power to create to
curate
sorry what we consume you can say
not having that zoning out blocking that
muting that unfollowing you
not joining this conversation oh i've
got a view on that
but is my perspective adding anything
unique that hasn't been said
probably not bob just said it 10 minutes
ago i'd just be saying it in a different
way
and if we if we do that
more more effectively more consciously
we'll not only uh sort of
rediscover the power in our outrage but
we'll have a better experience online
so many people kind of tap out of of
twitter and facebook like i can't take
it
i i hate it it's negative it's like you
can actually
you actually have the power to curate
who you follow
and to control what you consume
absolutely that's why i only follow i
think 98 people now and
taking that down from like 2 000 or
something has just cleaned it up because
i just see the things that are
interesting
not necessarily stuff that i agree with
i wonder how much of this
especially to do with social media is
to do with the frictionlessness
and the lack of consequence from
thought to projection of the things that
appear in our consciousness
so a hundred years ago in order for me
to go and tell
a large number of people anything it
would have actually been quite effortful
about to have got my boots on told the
wife that i was leaving you know jumped
on my horse or my cow or whatever you
ride cows anyway
um i can tell i'm such a farmer if
you're riding a cow in this story mate
commit thank you thank you that's not
not prejudice against cows not prejudice
against horses either yes i am
and i'm just like shouting it you know
like oh
it is there is a huge problem over here
and i'm like alerting people
it's so effortful that time in between
me
having a thought a rising consciousness
and then going right i'm off to get the
cow
like all of that different that process
would have given me chance to reflect
actually
is this worth me getting the cow out is
this worth
me going and shouting at all of my
neighbors and then
because there's no anonymity because
people actually have to see
you you see their reactions you're very
uh you're not detached from the act of
the saying or the receiving
of the words either and i wonder how
much this
always on communication constant
dopamine hits were not built to consume
human brain is not built to consume the
entire globe's news
in real time like by definition
obviously we're not
and then when again you have this
frictionless sort of
brain to mouth or keypad
system that we've got going on at the
moment i think that
might lend people to say a lot of things
that they maybe don't agree with and
obviously that pushes them out into
these extremes
absolutely like you've hit the nail on
the head that is
a huge part of the issue it's it's the
speed of the internet right and people
often find themselves wanting to be fast
rather than factual
right it's like i bet i better sum up
how i feel about this very quickly
as opposed to okay let me read this and
let me
take this in and let me you know have a
beat we don't give ourselves
that beat and again as you said a great
point we're not built
to consume the world's news right
in in real time which is why you
find click bait is the is the source
of so much outrage but we haven't got
time to consume the whole article
so i am going to base my judgment on
that headline
right so if that headline says
chrissy teigen aboard jeffrey epstein's
private jet [ __ ] [ __ ]
chris higgs is a pedophile you know what
i mean that like
i i i that's how i have to consume the
news
so now pretty teagan's a baddie in my
eyes i've got time to read the article
and that's how so much of our news
is consumed and that's why we often get
ourselves
in a pickle with our outrage because we
haven't
done the due diligence we haven't
actually
researched what it is we're angry about
or we've we've got angry about a 25
second clip of an interview
oh i kind of got time to unread the
whole thing or haven't got time to go
and watch the whole interview
i'm gonna base my judgment on this bit
that was taken entirely out of context
and that is how i'm going to form my
judgment it's this issue of
speed which seems to have rid us of all
our critical
thinking and it's another it's another
reason why our outrage is in a state of
disrepair
the thinly spread outrage which we're
giving back
might actually be a reflection
of this thinly consumed information
coming in
it seems like that that would make quite
a bit of sense that
no one has the time to genuinely connect
with a social cause that they
thoroughly care about because there's
three a day
that they need to try and keep up with
exactly
exactly we are we are the sort of the
cure and the cause
of of of this thing we we
are putting out what we're consuming
and then we're consuming what was being
put out and we're just in this sort of
horrible dystopian echo chamber
it's a carousel that i want to get off
mate so i've had this
this is one of the proofs which is
actually really cool oh
i know this is early did you ever get
one of those i did that's a that is
that's for one day i've had that exactly
i'm going to get you
so sign this for me but this has been
this has been with me
since february beginning of the year
yeah yes
so what would you if you were to do an
appendix
to this based on from when when you
finished writing it until now
would there have been anything else that
you would have thrown in was there some
stuff that appeared
and obviously you were like we need to
get the book out now but also stuff that
was like [ __ ]
like a wish i wish i could have put that
situation in or that situation
is there anything that's appeared in
2020 that you you would have liked to
have had
i think the the great thing about this
book
is that as i said it it could have come
out at any time
because it's just it's symptomatic of
the world we're living in and if i had
written it next year or the year after
there would have just been a different
set of case studies
right making the same points but a
different set of case studies
jk rowling for example is
as much as i've tried to disconnect from
these instances of cancel culture which
as i'll always give the caveat that
cancel culture is a myth
but jk rowling
it it fascinates me because
everyone is like jake jk rowling has
been cancelled
this is this is the problem with this
idea of cancel culture
right it doesn't exist okay jk rowling
has not been cancelled
all right people are not burning their
hogwarts merch right people are not
they're not shutting down harry potter
land
they're not her books are still
performing well
the the issue with with jk rowling
speaking out against cancel culture is
what fascinates me more
than this idea of cancer culture itself
because
we've created a climate where people can
evade accountability
by hiding behind this idea of council
culture so
rather than saying maybe i've messed up
here
and i need to have conversations and i
need to go for a bit of self-reckoning
you can say the world's gone mad look
they're bullying me
and you can hide behind this this veil
which almost inverts the entire thing
and makes
and makes you a victim and i write about
this in in the book just with a
different reference in the book
it's danny baker who has said um you
know he put that picture out of
a sort of newborn royal baby a monkey i
don't know monkeys as a motif
returned in this book um
but yes he put he put a picture out of a
monkey in reference to the royal baby
got fired from his bbc radio job and
rather than saying
[ __ ] that was tone deaf and i
completely get why it appears offensive
for me to post a picture of a monkey uh
in reference to a biracial
baby the first glimpse of melanin in the
royal family
there's some unconscious bias maybe on
my part that i'm my mind's even posting
a monkey picture
his reaction was cancel culture man
these snowflakes man it's like the
world's gone crazy
and that's part of the issue with
cancer culture is that it's
it's created a a
curtain behind which you can you can
actually hide
from your transgressions and divert the
conversation and make it about free
speech
and make it about censorship rather than
actually
accepting that you may have made a bad
decision
you may have had a poor choice of words
you may have expressed yourself wrongly
rather than accepting that there's now
something to hide behind
there has to be a time when that's not
the case though for instance i don't
know whether you looked at
you know remember mario lopez from saved
by
by the bell yeah did you see ac slater
ac slayer yeah he just hasn't aged at
all
um did you see what he said about
uh children undergoing gender
reassignment
under the age of three what did he say
bloody hell this is like maybe you're in
a bit ago now i spoke to
andrew doyle on the show about this and
um basically it was the most measured
pedestrian statement i've ever seen
from someone no one reasonable would
have taken
offense at this and he essentially said
this long-winded
loads of hyperbole loads of caveats and
then he
eventually says i don't know if children
under the age of three should be being
told that they're perhaps the wrong
gender
like you know my business partner's
kid is like a fireman one minute then a
pulseman the next then a a
astronaut the next and blah blah blah i
don't think that any of those
and he said this real gentle sentence
put it out there and just got
annihilated there were people calling
for his head
mtv three days later he gives
the the most groveling i have educated
myself i am
i've always been an ardent supporter of
the lgbtq plus community i
believe in this i i have furthered blah
blah blah
and i just think that there was nothing
wrong
with what you said you're talking about
people who were too young to have sex
but are young enough to have their
gender reassigned
like i don't know
that that to me seems like one of the
times where cancer culture does
come for someone
the council culture in situations like
this
which is which is what one of many
it's difficult when people are clumsy in
their messaging
right and often we mean well we we're
trying to say something
we've inadvertently offended somebody
right we
we see this happening a lot
the weight of public opinion
is such that we are now just stifling
conversation
where even like i want to call him aces
later
mario lopez may have
had a conversation with a a parent
of a a trans boy later on down the line
and actually been like you know bloody
hell i actually never been in that
situation
i've now had some conversations
as much as i think i my idea was rooted
in in
in sense i can kind of see why
there may be exceptions to that right
what what we've done though is we've
stifled it and you force someone into a
corner
you force them to renounce their feeling
and you've
just kind of hustled an apology out of
somebody which again i write about in
the book these kind of hustled
apologies which actually mean nothing at
all and
my fear around that is that we're just
kind of creating this sort of dystopian
future man
where everyone is scared to speak
everyone's scared to drive an
suv because they're gonna look like they
don't care about the environment
you know and everybody just
wears gray because anything else just in
case you culturally appropriate
something
exactly so can't can't wear anything
that might be a material
that is in some way indigenous to some
other place everybody's just
their their hair's we're just gonna have
to just not have our hair in any style
um i i fear that
where we're kind of just listening to
elevator music and driving our hybrid
cars
to just be as inoffensive as possible
and as as black mirror as it sounds
i feel as if if there's not an outrage
intervention that that is actually where
where we're headed where there will be
no more mario lopez's because nobody's
speaking
exactly well i mean i feel that as well
on this show like i try and just
have as little filter as possible from
brain to mouth so that the audience has
faith that what they hear
is what i think thankfully i have quite
usually have quite reasonable views as
opposed to if i was someone who is
having a self-centered all the time or
just
immediately being bothered but i feel
that i'm like
oh god is this wrong because last year
it maybe wasn't so wrong but this year
i'm seeing people getting in real bother
for
talking about things around these so
when the rules are always changing
yeah it can be really really worrying
and if that's someone
like myself and and you who talk a lot
who
you professionally what about the person
on the street they're not supposed to be
a professional they're not supposed to
spend their time
really finding the nuance of where their
position sits
exactly and that is i i start one of the
chapters in the book saying
i have written this book out of sheer
terror
right i'm writing this book because i
think if somebody doesn't write it
it's just who's going to be left just
the pope
you know and then the public will [ __ ]
up he's too white yeah then
then there'll be some skeletons in the
closet there it's not as if
we're creating a framework of
perfection um and sort of
moral high ground we're raising the
barter levels that we ourselves will at
some point fall short of
right so we're we're kind of placing
this parameter
around acceptable behavior which is
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller
until until none of us are in it and
it's that
that's what terrifies me and that's part
of why i i wrote the book as you say
in a vocation where you're a broadcaster
or a podcaster
where you're literally you're
documenting your views
right now we're saying this is how i
feel in 2020 dig this up in 2040 we've
literally
we've put it out there now right and on
social media
you're documenting your views in a
landscape that is ever-changing
and you are putting something there in
perpetuity
that we can now dig up in
six seven years and say oh god
you you said you don't think that used
to we don't say woman anymore
how how archaic i know you know
how long should someone be held
accountable for a thing that happened
in the past because we're seeing a lot
of sort of
past experiences get dredged up yeah
where's the
where's the line for that again
these things are are subjective right so
there are for example there are people
who have just been on twitter
for 12 years and look it was the wild
wild west back then
all right so you've got somebody who
joined twitter when they were 14
and said some absolutely ridiculous [ __ ]
uh but now they're they're 26
and [ __ ] their potential employer
has found out that who they were they
were they were body
shaming um some tv presenter uh
when they were 14. right there needs
there needs to be
a certain level of of common sense right
if you were saying something 12 years
ago
but you're a 60 year old man and
you were you were still in your 40s and
your your opinions were well formed
i think these things need to be need to
be handled
on a case-by-case basis but it's like
it's like with cultural moments like
like little britain
and 40 towers where it's so difficult
because
again tones change
attitudes change that that
is the nature of of the world where
we're living in right and what what
frustrates me
with the mob is this idea
that you have to be tethered to your
attitudes
right if you if you felt that way then
or you made that show
then that must be reflective of how you
feel now
right if everything we are doing
is for the purposes of progress so if we
are getting outraged because
we want gender pay gaps to
disappear if we're being outraged
because we want policies to change or we
want attitudes to change
we are out there we're protesting in the
streets because we want things to change
then we see that there's a capacity for
change you can't have both
you can't say look at who you used to be
you'll never change
while saying but i'm gonna go and out
here and protest and
hope for change you cannot have it both
ways
if you're going to
contribute to the fight for change you
have to also
accept that people have the capacity to
change and i feel like there's a real
lack of compassion uh on
on the internet at the moment especially
when it comes to sort of retrospective
rage
things that you said then things that
you felt then
and i said that there's going to be
nuance in in
in these different cases but for the
most part
if somebody has been held accountable
and they've said
i i said that eight years ago and i'm
ashamed
and i'm embarrassed and i do not stand
by that person
i was eight years ago there needs to be
the space to allow for that
you know you can't say no not having
that you you are cancelled
for who you were in 2012 because
you you genuinely you cannot you cannot
have it both ways
it's dangerous to judge the actions of
today by the
uh judge the actions of yesterday by the
rules of today like really really
dangerous
um and it's the john cleese thing the
faulty towers thing such a good example
you're talking decade was it like 1970s
something like that
like i'm not i'm not sure of the date
but that look
there is blackface
40 towers slavery
that there is so much which in its time
was accepted right
and yeah we we cannot turn a blind eye
to the world we once lived in
and and that that's where sometimes i'm
like should these things be coming down
should you just delete 40 towers
should you just delete little britain or
do these things need to come with a
disclaimer
up front that says this is the world we
used to live in
you know or are are we going to
completely erase
the the the history and
the history that is littered with
bigotry it is it's littered with with
prejudice
i think it's actually a cop
out for the people that perpetuated
those views i think it's easy for you to
just
pretend you didn't didn't have those
views i think it's easy
to yank little britain down and um allow
matt lucas and david williams to escape
that that's that's too much of a cop-out
not
that that should exit continue to exist
as a representation of the tone of the
day
i and that's my honest opinion i
actually don't think
we should be pulling things off
streaming services and pretending they
didn't happen
because that allows you to
escape what was the tone of the day
you know that's that's how we make
lessons right
the lessons are created by us being able
to reflect on history you know one of
the
the greatest ever losses was the burning
of the library of alexandria
like if all of that compiled wisdom
hadn't been lost like it genuinely
i think we believe we're sort of these
technocratic gods that are always just
going to be omnipotent and all of our
future generations are going to remember
[ __ ]
it's like no there is no cultural cannon
that will remember little britain in 100
years time
if you decide to or if you decide to
delete anything if you get rid of all of
the memories of all of this stuff
and it's only available on [ __ ] vhs
like to be put into a machine that no
one has anymore
that very very much will disappear
from the the artifacts the architecture
of cultural history
and then then what happens are you do
you just have to re-learn that lesson
again
is it like oh okay well we don't have
that we don't have the proof that that
lesson went wrong so like
might just stumble upon it again yeah
and look it's all
it's a bloody it's a tapestry isn't it
like our
experience um as
humanity's experience existence is a
tapestry
of everything that has happened you
can't just be like
don't like don't like how that patch
looks anymore it's part it's part of it
i'm afraid
like part of this quilt is gonna be
[ __ ] ugly
and it's it's what we've built and
as we progress we will like the look of
it more
right you can't just start unstitching
all the other [ __ ] right
and i was having this conversation the
other day
about gwen stefani right what's she done
now what's she done
she hasn't done anything now if if you
look at
if you look at old gwen stefani videos
right where she had a bindi
she had dreadlocks and she had three
japanese girls on
leashes this was her look
gwen stefani would never get away with
that you
you just couldn't it's like you're
offending everybody
it's almost like gwen's gone out of her
way to fight
how many different cultures she can
appropriate
how many birds can i kill with one song
right
and you'd you'd never get away with it
now but
i was a gwen stefani fan when gwen
stefani was was out
and i didn't recognize
how actually under the lens of of
woke 2020 how awful this is going to
look
i can't just erase my experience
as a teen that quite enjoyed a bit of
hey baby by
gwen stefani right and it it's about as
you say
just taking these as as lessons as
things to learn from and accepting that
look
we will we will like the look of our of
our tapestry
the more we progress it's good to
reflect on the fact that you were
present when that sort of stuff came up
as well right because it reminds us
that we were also either
um ignorant or willfully blind or
um a part of whatever society and
structure allowed anything in the past
like
uh indiana jones and raiders of the lost
ark was put on
variety's 10 films which should come
with a warning label
because it showed stereotypical
depictions of hindu people
as the people that will try and take
your heart out as
the evil villains and uh once upon a
time in hollywood is also a part of that
list
um a whole bunch of other other movies
when those movies came out i i haven't
been seeing this huge campaign for
raiders the lost ark to come down over
the last 30 years
like people outside of harrison ford's
house with pickets which means that you
were there
then but your opinions have changed to
now
and it harks back to what you said about
growth like if you
opinions are different i would i would
give that the caveat though
that quite often
people who are the the butt of the joke
right and
quite often you have movies and you have
tv programs that punch down
right let's take the piss out of indian
people let's take the piss out of
of black people let's take the piss out
of women right
the nature of so much dated media
punched down
and you don't get that as much now but
the people who were
the target or or the bot of the joke
weren't necessarily empowered or in a
position to say
not really enjoying this right so
it does always need to come with a with
a caveat but there's no blanket rule
that says that was the past and we can't
dwell on the past again
this is kind of what my book is about
every situation
is nuanced right there's no paint by
numbers response
that is going to fit every single
instance of of outrage
and there will be there will be people
that that watch little britain and were
offended
right that were offended by its
depiction of of of of chav culture
and felt that it was classist but there
was no outlet
or they didn't feel like what am i gonna
say you know everyone's enjoying the
show
or there'll be people that were
uncomfortable with the black face
that now feel as though the
the titus has changed and actually i
i can say that i felt this way
you know so there is always going to be
be that side and it's
and it's important which is why i say
it's you can't be
scared of that gray area man like so
so much of our or our online arguments
are because we refuse to accept that
there's a gray area
and there almost always is any
non-typical view that someone holds if
you say i am a this person conservative
a person of jewish heritage chinese
whatever it might be
if you have let's say you're a
conservative but you're also pro-life
that is seen as a [ __ ] in your armor as
like a weakness
in your viewpoint and i think that that
is one of the reasons why people
seem to be taking their views wholesale
rather than piecemeal
that it's like i am a this i love that i
love that yeah
therefore i'm gonna go through the rest
of it that's not an original thought
that is me
taking it from someone else but i don't
know who it is so we're gonna i'm the
closest person that we're gonna
reference
reference
but yeah that during a debate if you
have a nuanced view the other side sees
that as a weakness
ah you see you see i knew he wasn't
really
pro-trump democrat whatever it might be
because he doesn't agree on this and
he's like yeah yeah
obviously i don't because i don't happen
to be donald trump i don't happen to be
joe biden i don't have to be like the
this particular person
and with that in mind i'm going to have
these little nuances and these gray
areas
and i write in the book about tribalism
which is
something that really it we just career
down these cul-de-sacs of opinion
because we feel railroaded by our tribes
right
so you might feel as though [ __ ] i'm a
i'm a vegan from the
free counties and i've got a stand for
everything
that is an affront to my community and
my veganism
and i i can't fall outside
of the parameters of what it means to be
in that tribe so
often we find people speaking up
because it's an affront
to their tribe not necessarily because
they personally are offended
but because they feel they're supposed
to be offended right
[ __ ] this person has said something
about women
[ __ ] i'm not that offended but i have
got a feminism podcast i better say
something
do you know what i mean or and you get
you get so much of that
people feeling as though because of the
groups to which they subscribe that they
have to respond
to everything or they're letting their
tribe down and that
that is when you get people shouting
about a h m hoodie
because i'm black and i've got to be
angry about the monkey hoodie right
you know and it's it's that which
doesn't allow for nuance quite often
it's like vicinity offense
it's like this isn't something i'm
offended by but it's kind of
it's kind of there's someone near me
that might have done my realm
um so what can people do how can the
listeners move forward and and that sort
of act a little bit better if you were
to
leave people with some tips of how to be
better outrageous how can we make
outrage great
oh again this is there are so many this
is like a three-step
guide right it's it's about
you figuring out for yourself
what you care about again the the worst
thing the biggest disservice i could
have done in this book is
tell people what to care about i don't
like i
just it it it doesn't work to try and as
i say
fit a framework around somebody else's
ideas and belief systems that's the
beauty of humanity
there are going to be little differences
in all of us
what i will always say is you you owe it
to yourself to only be outraged
by that which truly outrages you
and that seems like a really sensible
concept like yeah of course i'm only
outraged by things that
outrage me that no you you may
think you are genuinely outraged but if
you were genuinely outraged
then you want to get something out of it
right
the purpose of outrage is progress
it's it's the only reason outrage should
exist is because you feel something
needs to change
right i am outraged by this because
these
these policies are are
archaic i'm against this because
i feel as though it is racist it's
offensive it's sexist and and
that needs to change i want this to
happen
right which is why i continue to use
the analogy of outrageous currency
treat your outrage as you would a real
investment
right you wouldn't blindly be like i'll
put 5k
in that i'll put 10k in that these are
your life savings
right your outrage is your emotional
life savings
right it is it is yours to invest
as you see fit every single time you are
outraged
you are spending your currency you are
investing it
stop doing it blindly stop doing it
where you are not seeking a return on
your investment because you are pouring
your outrage
down the drain because you want to see a
return on your investment and you owe
that to yourself
i really really hope that the internet
takes heed of this
it sounds like a much nicer place to
live whatever's inside
outrage seems like a much more wonderful
place to be than we are right now
yeah i just i just think we need
an intervention which is what this book
was it's for all the outraged junkies
or friends of junkies you know sometimes
your crackhead friend is not going to
read the book and you've got to read it
for them right
so this is for anybody in need of an
intervention or who knows somebody that
might
i love it uh it will be linked in the
show notes below
of course if you want to go and check
this out it will be available on amazon
do you say that you've done you've done
an audio version as well so you've done
the kit is it ordered there's an audio
book
yeah i mean if you're not sick of my
voice
an hour into this podcast there's some
more in the audiobook if you if you
don't like this
tone go for the hardback yes something
else it's a fairly easy read as well
right you know you could probably crack
this out
in a few days but it's really dense and
there's some there's some great laughs
in so
yeah linked in the show notes below
anything else you want to plug daddy
anywhere
other places that people should go no
read the book
share it uh spread the word i think
this is one of those books i'm not so
much fussed with people
going out and buying it i would love you
to read this book and just give it to
somebody else
and then tell them to give it to
somebody else it's not about shifting
the units on this one
i think it's about continuing the
conversation so please
um yeah recycle your outraged book once
you've read it
i love that that's a really good
sentiment thank you so much for your
time that is awesome and
as i say linked in the show notes below
anyone wants to go and get this go and
check it out
thanks so much mate